[Music]
how's it going bros my name is peter pan
today we're looking at another 90 days
fiance and oh boy oh boy
is this gonna be an interesting one this
time we're meeting a female American
whose name is Nicole she's 22 years old
and she's about to meet the love of her
life they are engaged I think I'm not
sure she's a little big TLC wrote thank
[Music]
God I love the best show ever I would
never have expected all right let's
watch now so we need Nicole she's a
mother
classic American family since I told my
family about the trip they've been very
against it and really want me to not go
[Music]
to buses food I'm just protecting a
co-owner trip to Morocco and that this
guy isn't in it for whatever reason it
for that he actually likes her and loves
her and that he's going to take care of
her and she's a man they seemed pretty
hopeful that things are gonna go right
please for the love of God make her not
use her for their money
my family support date different
nationalities and different work ethics
and religions and Whang everything is
different
damn opinionated kid huh velu shared kid
the American version with all right I'm
curious who the guy is that she's gonna
meet this guy is the love of your life
trying to find out is having potato
chips as on the dinner table not bad not
bad that's how you know you're in
America trying to find out it is it
worth it no I don't think it is honey if
he's alone in my life it's not worth you
trying to find out not if what his
intentions are wrong Dan who is this guy
he must be absolutely the worst Nicole's
a beautiful girl yeah but she's not you
know the most beautiful girl out there
and as bura imagine your parents
describing you like that on TV
nice nice one mom thanks mom
is a person not the best way there's
this expression if you don't have
anything nice to say they don't say
anything at all and I feel like that
should apply your kids on national
television at least I know what she's
coming from it's like she's questioning
what this guy's motives are I guess
we're just gonna have to find out he's a
very handsome man and damn floor gang
house understand with this 20% muscle
increase absolutely
so Nikola takes off to Morocco that's
where her lover or her life is I've been
to Morocco it's a very unique place I
think if you're not ready for the
culture change that it will be a big
shot but it's very beautiful and the
food is amazing take good care of my
baby I'm trusting you I'm so curious
yeah that sounded sincere I think it's
good that he's spoken to the parents at
least maybe I don't know I don't know I
find the scientists because I obviously
went met my wife online in a completely
different country but Morocco that's
very different from America
I hope she's ready for it I really do
Nicole she's my fiancee we've been
waiting for a long time to meet and be
together so that's why she come to Marco
and you know I'm really excited in that
can't wait to go to the airport to be
home from there
all right yeah I'm just excited it's
exciting I believe it so let's go my
friend Hamza is coming because he's my
best friend so he want also to meet her
oh that's sweet what you feel now
you know I just maybe she will not like
Morocco you know no maracas and maracas
she's a nice place so they're in
Marrakech that's where I've been yet
it's a nice place
yes it's a nice place it's ups and downs
we March has made a vlog there there's
obviously like really bad parts of it
but a lot of it is really beautiful I
don't want to it sound so forth I don't
know it's as funny seeing his reaction
cuz he knows she's gonna get shot from
this I've been there I've been to that
therefore I'm about to meet the love of
my life
like seriously she's like white you
can't miss her because she's American
yeah yeah alright about to meet the love
of my life for the first time ever
[Music]
I feel my heart Wow nice microphone
action did you hear that okay okay can
we stop hugging now okay when she
dropped her bag so dramatic I almost
threw up these comments are always so
over-the-top my god I'm hungry are you
seriously cut what the hell it's a long
flight
don't be so judge for the first time I
see that she's pretty and you know it's
cute when I see her I mean her body I
was surprised that she's bigger little
bear I'm guessing she never sent him
full body pics oh so they go to the
market to buy some food it's like being
like Dan if the foodie market was so
good
I mean that's not what you say when it
was good but damn all the veggies was so
good there all the food was my god it's
a bit different from potato chips on the
dinner table
this is definitely different when I'm
used to if I even see fresh products
it's usually in a supermarket in the
frigerator section that's what I'm used
to for fresh ingredients okay so time to
go find some of the nuts they're going
to get some fresh chicken you had them
in the box
goddamn the smell of chicken it's the
best why are the chickens baby I like
how she's acting like this is so strange
do you be do you not know where your
food comes from seems like everyone's so
attached detached from from it I would
never hurt an animal by chicken and beef
omnomnomnom
goddamn eat what you want obviously but
I feel like we're so detached from our
food we made the process so easy for us
that's why my philosophy is that I'll
eat what I would kill because killing
things is uncomfortable most people
wouldn't and at least there's a level of
respect there instead of completely
distancing yourself from what goes
through to these animals which isn't
fair a lot of the times it came a little
bit preachy there but I don't know just
like oh it's so weird it's in the cage
we'll move but you're gonna kill it
world I don't really want to see you
know that was taken before I go to cook
it like I just want it to be make you
feel bad huh everyone hypocrite except
me oh I'm joking today as I'm taking me
some market in Marrakesh and technically
we're not supposed to hug or kiss in
public but that's gonna be really hard
for me
oh no God girl you're in a different
country I've been there
Wow making out with snakes and I didn't
miss out on that oh she did not like
that and whether you agree or not aware
it is right you're still visiting
someone else's country you have to be
respectful of that you can tell us you
took that personally too I mean that's
not even the case this is how it is
there oh my god [ __ ] me
yeah I can understand things no you're
not understanding things that's the
problem
I can understand things oh man I don't
know I'm curious what you guys think
this is someone else's country yeah you
just got him this is how it is just
feels entitled but I don't know I I
don't know woman who likes like physical
affirmation you know hugs and kisses and
even like little weird
cute things you know just physical stuff
I guess it's like reassuring that you
know he just thought he looks so done
you know he's happy with me I don't know
it's just like not being able to do
those things it really sucks like it's
really upsetting sucks it's so upsetting
I can't do whatever I want
they set this up to make it seem like he
was the bad guy but I don't know man I
ain't seen any of it so far at leaves so
she ran out and he just tried to stop
her if she doesn't get her weight around
he's not dragging her around he was
trying to protect her why are you
yelling
you're the not paying this guy does not
like arguing in public trying to tell me
how to be we're just pretty better and
I'm a little worried that we're already
having an argument on the first day
we in the first day that I'm here and I
was already thinking he could just tell
me to shut up this time he's really
gonna learn quick that that's not what
he can do
I'm amazed mom and I just need you to
listen you know what are they even
arguing about god this is exhausting to
look at yeah ever feeling this is not
gonna work out
I just a hunch I wanted to give her like
chocolates you said I can't do it to her
yeah now she can have brain it's like
really not Hilton the chicken is good
for her chicken like chicken nuggets are
not bad I don't know about you but I
wouldn't take health advice from from
her that's all I'm going to say I love
how he doesn't yell just calmly tell ya
later kid price overweight mother that's
my kid
welcome to America
dear mom makes like they do a belfie
food I miss the sharing not code for me
and just like being like fast for this
time I really wanted well just because I
always care about my health I think
frozen food and I cannot make fresh
home-cooked meals every day what rosin
is okay folks not to touch I'm not a
stay-at-home mom like your sister and
your mom was or I can't why is this
social walk you know this and Bruce just
need to try try I'm not against trying
it's just I was definitely against
trying she seems like the kind of person
that tries once ah this is impossible I
can't do this oh man you promised me
that you're gonna change and do you
think that she'll go to gym and eat
healthy
oh I mentioned that I should make some
lifestyle changes if we really want to
be like to get those customers should
change you know I can't if you can I can
okay god I'm not hopeful at all oh my
gosh it was going well but I got
stressed out so I just kind of stopped
so oh my god I was right
holy shait I did it but stressed they're
too much so they go to the desert ride
some epic camels we have time to do this
unfortunately no super high the sand
doesn't work out your camera rise sex
[Music]
cam will be like brah he sprinkles the
word honey and sentences for damage
control that's good Cameron be like wait
that thing is gonna ride me obviously
you shouldn't have to change completely
for your partner that's not it at all
but a partner can help you inspire you
to be happy more healthier that's not a
bad thing I'm not trying to shame anyone
for being out of shape either I know
it's hard losing weight a lot of a lot a
lot of people struggle with it there
it's just how it is but she seems to
meet it with so much anger and oh it's
too hard I can't do it you have someone
there that can help you use that she
seems to resist him for it almost or
resent him I don't know that's just what
I picked up can you please stop
just the arguing about you know just
trying to be like mocking people just
for one month I'm not
I know about China because me to be
Moroccan didn't you fall in love me
because I'm not rocking if I see stuff
like this hit me it doesn't mean that I
don't love you okay I just woman bye I
love you no way and if I said things
like you should change it doesn't mean
that I give up a knee or something you
know it's like she's given up on herself
I'm now your perfect woman
boohoo me that's not it at all he's
trying to help you that's what I'm
picking up at least curious where you
guys think
honey's under and change you he's asking
to kindly respect their culture he
deserves the green card for his patience
as a Moroccan myself I'm super surprised
he stayed calm during this argument
because most guys would throw a tantrum
because you don't play no games with no
Moroccan and especially you do not risk
disrespect once culture he he's been
very calm throughout all of this maybe
he's just pulling it through for the
cameras I don't know but I can't really
fault him on anything so far and want to
be healthy but I don't think I need to
change myself for a man for him to love
me because if he loves me she loved me
for who I am
that attitude is like saying I'm perfect
and I should be praised for being
perfect at all times obviously you love
someone you love someone but encouraging
someone to be better shouldn't be met
with oh you don't think I'm perfect oh
I'm not good enough for you like to go
to gym and like to not be lazy I'm not
lazy some things you're do you know why
you're asking from me right now
don't go 2 jaemin if that doesn't happen
I'm not sure I'm going to America Oh
[Music]
now I want you to believe you know the
woman that's not comfortably okay I
really like him he isn't fat-shaming he
only wants her to be healthy is he
pushing her too hard and congrat later
after she is done with the exercise
physically I'm talking to Nicole but
it's not like it just like 55% you put a
number on it are you attracted to me no
matter what I know I love you just
please what are you attracted to me oh
my god I love this so painful how do
they find these people it's so perfect I
love it it doesn't seem like that
interesting premise of a show but it
truly is so finally they go through this
big fight and I'm not sure what's
happening as always you want to escape
from Nicole or just go upstairs
sorry that was a load joke
what is happening can't even look as a
single person I am just a bunch a group
of Americans I'm just American to him
okay Trump is our prep man in a way I do
feel for her let me try and be nice it
seems like she knows about the issues
but she thinks it's too hard to overcome
them so once a person her life comes in
and can actually help her to push
herself when she realizes that she can't
do it or doesn't want to do it she gets
frustrated at him when in reality she's
been frustrated with herself
mr. armchair psychologist over here I'm
sure she's sweet at some point and I'm
pretty sure he wouldn't see her the
other way
is he gonna confront her transform is
respectful to me just because of what I
did wait what did she do you know before
I cheated on him things were amazing
uh-huh after it he did it
[Music]
before I cheated on him
things were amazing and then after I
cheated on him things changed oh my god
everything was every hope I had for you
Nicole just went out the window there my
god how can you be so unselfish
my accidents and consequences it's not
fair to me that I did something bad
unbelievable he took advantage of this
Aires yeah she cheated and acts like a
victim Oh God sounds like it is honey oh
my god oh my god that was crazy
I can't believe it in the beginning as
well family would seem so concerned like
you know my rock is a very different
country it's big culture change and the
even the kid was like I had different
values different lifestyles different
jobs all these things and she just like
and she so obviously didn't even trying
gosh what a great show hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did hit like
subscribe thanks for coming remember all
the member revenue goes to charity I
decided this month is going to Yemen the
humanitarian crisis so it's going to
work the Save the Children it's a great
charity and and it will go specifically
for the Yemen issue that I'm donating
towards so I just want to say thanks to
everyone for become a member if we
really made a big impact I'll post about
it in the community because once it's
all done but I just wanted to announce
that I think it's really cool I'm really
proud of you guys and yeah see you
tomorrow
Adel profesh
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and pull
troops awaits
OOP tears coming to Nintendo's wait and
remember it has a very big TV pre-order
promotion heavy
and there we assetbook birthday girl ran
away
[Music]